[Musik]
das zusammen herzlich willkommen an den
empfangsgeräten zu zdf heute live mit
ihrem live stream zu aktuellen
ereignissen
da geht es heute um die sache mit der
migration und der flucht und der
europäischen union denn seit 2005 10
späten ist es ist ja klar dass das
system wie wir ist derzeit in der eu
haben nicht so richtig funktioniert da
hat die eu grenzschutzagentur in diesem
jahr 1,8 millionen
die reguläre grenzübertritte wie das im
amtsdeutsch heißt registriert und dann
wurde halt klar das system was in den
90er jahren aufgedeckt wurde ist einfach
so nicht mehr zeitgemäß und kann
eigentlich nicht funktionieren
die zahlen sind heute längst nicht mehr
so hoch wie 2015 aber trotzdem ist das
problem immer noch da die eu hat halt
dafür gesorgt dass es schwieriger wird
für menschen nach europa zu kommen aber
so einen richtigen lösungsversuch ist
das nicht das erinnert er so mehr daran
ein kaputtes auto mit gaffa tape und
spucke ein bisschen wieder in fahrt zu
bringen
das sehen wir unter anderem an der lage
auf lesbos
da wollen wir uns mal aktuelle bilder
anschauen dort hat ja vor wenigen tagen
oder vor zwei wochen ungefähr hat das
lager gebrannt das war gloria die
menschen mussten umziehen alle 12.000
menschen die noch auf der insel sind
sollen jetzt in ein neues camp umziehen
aber auch da gibt es beschwerden jetzt
schon von den menschen dort vor ort gibt
zu wenig wasser es gebe zu wenig essen
sie müssen lange anstehen das würde an
strom fehlen und auch an toiletten
da sehen wir hier die langen schlangen
am camp das heißt es dass alles andere
als eine wirklich tragbare situation auf
lange zeit und da will die eu kommission
jetzt ran eu kommissionspräsidenten
ursula von der leyen will sich gleich
äußern oder äußert sich gerade vor der
presse das weiß ich gerade derzeit noch
nicht aber sie wird auf jeden fall ein
paar worte sprechen und dann wird es
eine pressekonferenz geben mit der eu
kommissarin emma johansson aus schweden
das ist kommissarin für inneres und mit
dem eu-kommissar für europäische
lebensweise für die förderung der
europäischen lebensreise margaritis
chinas aus griechenland der ist auch
vizepräsident der eu kommission und die
beiden wollen einen zehn punkte plan
vorstellen
wie diese ganze sache mit flucht und
migration in der eu anders gelöst werden
kann wir sprechen jetzt erstmal mit
meinem kollegen stefan leifert in
brüssel der das ganze für uns beobachtet
gleich auch mit gerald knaus soziologe
und migrationsforscher der den eu
flüchtlinge mit der türkei 2016 mit
ihnen die wege geleitet hat und der das
ganze für uns auch nochmal einordnet
wird aber erste frage erst mal an stefan
während wir darauf warten dass in
brüssel sich was tut warum oder glaubst
du dass sich jetzt tatsächlich etwas
ändern könnte könnten die
kommissionsvorschläge tatsächlich diesen
gordischen knoten wir so oft genannt
wird zum platzen bringen
naja es gibt zwei faktoren die
vielleicht dafür sprechen könnten das
eine was auch der kommission so ein
bisschen hoffnung macht ist die tatsache
dass sie sich jetzt ein jahr zeit
genommen hat um durch alle 27
mitgliedsstaaten zu tingeln also die
kommissare waren in berlin waren in wien
waren in budapest waren in allen eu
hauptstädten und haben auf grundlage
dieser gespräche bei denen sie natürlich
noch mal erfahren haben wie verworren
und wie kompliziert dieses thema ist auf
grundlage dieser gespräche dann das
entworfen was jetzt heute vorgestellt
wird also viele gespräche und der zweite
faktor der vielleicht auch dafür spricht
dass jetzt etwas passiert ist dass es
eigentlich bei allen inzwischen die
einsicht gibt dass dieser gordische
knoten so schwierig und so dick er auch
ist endlich durchschlagen werden muss
weil wir es hier nicht mit irgendeinem
thema zu tun haben sondern mit dem kern
streit der die europäische union im
moment in fast allen bereichen lernt und
diese lähmung aufzulösen das ist glaube
ich der wunsch aller so unterschiedlich
die positionen auch sind wir dürfen
keine wunder erwarten von dem was heute
passiert ich glaube das wäre eine zu
hohe erwartungen es werden erstmal alle
länder nach der vorstellung dieses plans
heute sagen dass sie enttäuscht sind
dass das nicht die erwartungen erfüllt
die sie eigentlich gehabt hatten aber
entscheidend werden dann die monate sein
die dann folgen und der kommission ist
bewusst dass das jetzt vielleicht der
letzte anlauf für die nächsten jahre
sein könnte überhaupt noch etwas bei dem
thema zu bewegen
das sind ja schöne aussichten wenn man
jetzt schon weiß dass hinter sich
während werden ursula von der leyen hat
sich gerade geäußert wurde mir gesagt du
hast zugehört glaube ich kannst du ganz
kurz zusammenfassen was sie gesagt hat
also dieser anlauf denen die kommission
jetzt unternimmt der besteht ganz grob
aus zwei versuchen auf die parteien die
so zerstritten sind bei diesem thema
zuzugehen
machen wir es mal ganz schlicht wir
haben auf der einen seite die südländer
wie griechenland jetzt durch moor er
noch mal ganz akut oder auch italien die
die eu um hilfe bitten und die immer
wieder zu dem ergebnis kommen dass
system was wir im moment haben das
funktioniert nicht das führt zu einer
absoluten überlastung wir brauchen die
hilfe der anderen auf diese länder geht
von der leyen oder geht die eu
kommission zu mit der idee dass sie
künftig einen verpflichtenden
solidaritäts mechanismus einziehen will
in das europäische asylsystem wenn es in
diesen ländern zu krisensituationen
kommt auf die länder die bisher immer
strikt dagegen waren also nehmen wir zb
ungarn viktor waren österreich insgesamt
die die osteuropäischen staaten die sich
in dieser fische grad gruppe
zusammengetan haben die wollten ja immer
partout nicht dass es zu einem
verpflichtenden vorteil mechanismus
kommt nennen dazu führt dass diese
länder flüchtlinge anerkannte
flüchtlinge aufnehmen müssten
dazu muss es nicht zwingend kommen
sondern von der leyen wird erstellt
gerade vor dass es verschiedene formen
gibt solidarisch zu sein das muss nicht
die aufnahme von flüchtlingen sein
sondern das kann auch geld sein das kann
personal sein das kann hilfe bei
rückführung von flüchtlingen in ihre
herkunftsländer sein und das ist der
bogen den sie versucht zu spannen
solidarität auf der einen seite für die
südländer
auf der anderen seite aber flexible
möglichkeiten solidarisch zu sein so für
alle die jetzt gerade erst dazu kommen
wir warten darauf dass sich die eu
kommissare in brüssel frau eva johansson
aus schweden eu kommissarin für inneres
und der eu kommissar für die förderung
der europäischen lebensweise margaritis
chinas aus griechenland äußern werden zu
den vorschlägen der eu kommission wie
man jetzt diese ganze flüchtlings und
migrationsfragen innerhalb der eu
vielleicht besser lösen kann weil das
system das jetzt funktioniert nicht
stefan leifert unser korrespondent in
brüssel hat gerade schon mal angedeutet
dass es einen neuen fall
nicht in verpflichten den solidaritäts
mechanismus aus zugesagt geben könnte
oder geben wird für alle die jetzt nicht
ganz mehr auf der pfanne haben was
eigentlich das grundsätzliche problem
ist hat meine kollegin verschlingt das
noch mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst
rückblick das feuer in moria vor zwei
wochen
es hat auch die diskussion um die
aufnahme von geflüchteten neu entfacht
unter den eu staaten herrscht zumindest
weitgehend einigkeit darüber
eine lösung muss her und zwar schnell
viele sehen sie in der reform des dublin
systems danach ist derzeit das land zur
aufnahme verpflichtet in dass
asylbewerber zuerst eingereist sind also
meist die südlichen eu staaten
so gesehen im nachteil griechenland auf
den griechischen inseln vor der
türkischen küste ist die lage prekär
rund 27.000 flüchtlinge die meisten aus
afghanistan und syrien leben hier unter
teils erbärmlichen bedingungen helfen
verteilen
dazu gibt es noch kein konzept seitens
der eu nach dem feuer in moria haben
sich elf europäische länder nach und
nach bereit erklärt flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen
freiwillig kein einheitlicher weg der eu
also weil einige gar keine flüchtlinge
aufnehmen wollen
die osteuropäer halb skandinavien das
baltikum und österreich eine
grundsätzliche einigung in der
flüchtlingspolitik ein kompromiss mit
dem alle leben können das soll der
heutige tag bringen
die letzten versuche der vorigen eu
kommission waren stets gescheitert und
wir warten weiter darauf dass sich in
brüssel was tut dass dort die beiden
zuständigen kommissare vor die presse
treten wir gucken mal ganz kurz rüber
daher ist noch ein leeres podest das
heißt das kann auch ein paar minuten
dauern dann sprechen wir noch mal kurz
mit unserem korrespondenten stefan
leifert und gleich mit gerald knaus dem
österreichischen soziologen und
migrationsforscher ich habe auch schon
ein paar gramm kommentare hier bekommen
die wir gleich mit einfließen lassen
werden
ich kann euch doch wieder nur bitten
schwieriges thema das wissen wir seit
jahren seid bitte einigermaßen
freundlich und konstruktiv zu einander
vielleicht mal ganz grundsätzlich noch
mal stefan dieses dublin zwei abkommen
von dem die ganze zeit die rede ist
wasser dazu
dass die außen länder also die länder
mit eu-außengrenzen quasi zuständig sind
weil dort die menschen erstes ankommen
warum ist es überhaupt jemals so
getroffen worden das klingt nach einem
ganz ganz schlechten deal um einen
bekannten us präsidenten zu zitieren
man ist ja nachher immer schlauer und
wir müssen bedenken dass diese dann den
reformer oder zumindest die erste
version dieses dublin abkommens im jahr
1990 getroffen worden ist das wahr was
heutiger sicht wirklich eine andere welt
die eu bestand zum einen war es zwölf
mitgliedstaaten damals und die
migrationsströme waren damals auch
völlig andere wir sind damals nicht mit
zahlen konfrontiert gewesen wie wir sie
heute haben den ohren sechsstelligen
bereich oder auch über einer million
auch die herkunftsländer waren damals
ganz andere die eu erlebte dann kurz
nachdem berlin abkommen eine
flüchtlingswelle vor allem aus dem
ehemaligen jugoslawien jugoslawien
kriegs aber das was wir heute haben
existierte einfach so noch nicht das ist
das eine und das andere ist dass man
erst im laufe der jahre festgestellt hat
wozu das bei krisensituationen dann
eigentlich führt nämlich zu dieser
absoluten überlastung der länder an der
außengrenze griechenland und italien
sind so exemplarisch seien beispiele
dafür
und diese dublin-verordnung die über die
ganzen jahre gültig war und die sagen
wir mal so vor vier oder fünf jahren und
eindeutig zusammengebrochen ist die soll
jetzt abgelöst werden durch etwas neues
man kann jetzt von abschaffung sprechen
oder von reformen das ist glaube ich
wortklauberei entscheidend ist die frage
wird es gelingen einen mechanismus
einzuziehen der diese länder also
griechenland italien mit abstrichen auch
spanien am ende entlastet und dafür
sorgt dass diese krisensituation die wir
jetzt mehreren jahren und auch zuletzt
jetzt beispiel moria wieder erlebt haben
hilft zu vermeiden und da wird die
kommission gleich etwas vorstellen was
so ein abgestufter krisenmechanismus
sein wird die länder werden oder
krisensituationen werden so in drei
kategorien aufgeteilt das eine ist eine
akute krise die dazu führt dass ein
asylsystem eines landes völlig
überfordert ist
zweites szenario wird sein
es bahnt sich an dass eine krise auf ein
aufnahmeland wie griechenland oder
italien zu kommen könnte und das dritte
ist das was wir in den letzten monaten
und jahren auch immer wieder erlebt
haben das ankommen von flüchtlingsbooten
und die aufnahme von mittelmeer
geretteten flüchtling das wäre auch so
einer situation wo länder wie italien
und griechenland dann diesen
krisenmechanismus ziehen können das gab
es bisher nicht dass es eine einen
verpflichtenden mechanismus gibt der in
brüssel dann aktiviert werden kann von
diesen ländern und dann dazu führt dass
die anderen länder also deutschland also
österreich alle anderen verpflichtend
solidarität zeigen und leisten müssen
das ist das eine das andere ist dann
eben die frage welche form von
solidarität kann das sein das war bisher
ja immer dieser verknotete streit um die
frage der verpflichtenden aufnahme von
flüchtlingen davon will diese jetzige
kommission sec diesen konflikt will sie
nicht weiter austragen und sagt man kann
in solchen situationen dann helfen indem
man flüchtlinge aufnimmt aber es gibt
auch andere formen also zum beispiel
ungarn mal ganz plastisch gesprochen
könnte sagen
für die 50 zum spanischen ich muss kurz
bescheid rechnen wir wollten gern noch
mehr heiraten aussprechen aber ich höre
dass in brüssel die pressekonferenz
losgeht mit dem eu-kommissar für die
europäer und europäischen dienstreise
margaritis chinas und der eu kommissarin
für inneres über johansson aus schweden
wir schalten mal rüber nach brüssel und
hören was sie uns zu sagen haben
so jetzt sie treten vor die presse über
die sitzung des kollegiums heute
vormittag mittwoch 23 september ist das
datum vizepräsident chinas erhält das
wort er wird das mietauto übernehmen
zusammen mit kommissarin johansson wird
da dann das paket zur migration und asyl
vorstellen dass heute morgen dem
kollegium diskutiert wurde er
vizepräsident ein kilo ganze schon
herzlich willkommen
ich beginne mit dem rest der agenda des
kollegiums bevor ich eingekauft das soll
migrationsbericht wir haben über die
zukünftige aktionspläne zu kapitalmarkt
und entwicklung der jungs capital hatte
zugang zu finanzierung wird wichtig sein
damit auch super sich von der korona
währungskrise abholen kann
der aktionsplan zeigt den weg das paket
digitales finanzwesen stärkt die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit europas auch
innovationsfähigkeit im finanzsektor
verbraucher bekommen mehr auswahl mehr
chancen oder finanzdienstleister zugang
zur modernen zahlungswege mein kollege
dombrovskis wird morgen dazu eine
pressekonferenz geben
der herr neuer aktionsplan zur
intelligenter innovativer und
effizienter machen
die eu einkommen zu schützen genauso wie
gesundheit und wohlstand der bürger und
der wirtschaft kommissar pauli wird hier
unter verschiedenes hat die kommission
dann auch beschlossen dass eine
task-force einzusetzen
dieser task force soll und dabei helfen
die notsituationen auf lesbos noch so
lieber nach dem brand in moria wir haben
mit den griechischen behörden ein brot
projekte in die wege geleitet damit soll
ein neues aufnahmezentrum geschaffen
werden gehört zum neuen paket das wir
gleich vorstellen
damit wird gewährleistet dass migration
beim effizient gehandelt
das gute lebensbedingungen zu schaffen
werden wir sicherheit schnellere
verfahren und die verantwortung und die
solidarität besser ausgerufen werden
die task force wird in der gt raum
angesiedelt werden
sie steht unter der verantwortung von
kommissarin johansson aber das ganze ist
natürlich das ergebnis verschiedener
konsultationen und gesprächen mit frau
von allein mit frau merkel und herrn
mitsotakis die person in der kommission
die die leitung für diese taskforce
übernimmt ich muss noch eine
neubenennung in der kommission
ankündigen wir haben eine neue
stadtvertretung generaldirektor in der
gt home es handelt sich um den
österreichischen kollegen johannes noch
mal herzlichen glückwunsch
heute ist der internationale takte
gebärdensprache
die heutige pressekonferenz wird dann
auch in internationaler gebärdensprache
gedolmetscht werden
wir werden versuchen alle wöchentlichen
ried aus dem kollegium sitzung auch in
gebärden straße in der sprache
gedolmetscht dazubekommen bleiben sie am
ball
und jetzt da sozusagen zum hauptgericht
auf der speisekarte der heutigen
kollegiums das paket für migration und
asyl
es ist ein wichtiger augenblick wir
wissen dass es eine der wichtigsten
initiativen des kollegiums oder frau von
der leyen lange zeit arbeiten wir schon
daran aber nun ist der zeitpunkt
gekommen zu handeln
wir sehen die probleme bei der migration
in moria anders und diese probleme
ergeben sich nicht wegen europa sondern
weil europa nicht stark genug ist wir
sehen was es kostet dass wir nicht genug
europa haben
heute nun präsentieren zusammen mit der
käuferin einen kompromiss es ist ein
erstes ergebnis
wir versuchen nun zu einer einigung zu
gelangen
sie haben das wohl gesehen sowie
business auch das ist etwas das wir
nicht
bilaterale in valencia ausgeheckt haben
wir haben diesen viele konsultationen
durchgeführt anhörungen sind in den
eu-hauptstädten gewesen überall in der
eu haben mit allen staats und
regierungschefs gesprochen wochen haben
wir im europaparlament verbracht und wir
denken das was wir heute präsentieren
wirklich den bisherigen input in diesem
langen konsultationsverfahren auf den
punkt bringt
bei der migration ist das so gut dass er
alle mitgliedstaaten das vernommen
unterschiedlich wahrnehmen
man hat unterschiedliche blickwinkel
prioritäten es gibt unterschiedliche die
biografie ist unterschiedlich
herausforderung ich muss sagen
die sorge dass einen ist nie legitim als
die aller anderen alle sorgen verdienen
es anerkannte zu werden und angepasst zu
werden und genau das tun wir heute wir
hatten natürlich auch die lehren aus
2016 gezogen
die wunden von 2016 das scheitern der
europäische und da zu einer einigung zu
gelangen sind immer noch präsent und
spürbar und deswegen versuchen wir nun
einen neustart und wir wissen dass wir
alle im boot haben die präsidentin sagt
das war weniger minuten solidarität und
irgendwo antwort das bewusstsein sind
unsere leitmotive und solidarität und
verantwortungsbewusstsein sollten nie
mehr gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
wenn wir vielleicht ist das nämlich so
akzeptieren würden dann wären wir wieder
bei dem film von spielberg back to the
future man reist in zukunft nur um auf
die probleme der vergangenheit zu stoßen
neues paket also wie kann ich es am
besten beschreiben sohn wohl am besten
als ein haus mit drei stockwerken das
erste stockwerk eine sehr starke externe
dimension gestärkte partnerschaften mit
herkunfts und transitländern dann ein
striktes management unserer außengrenzen
und strenge aber faire interner regeln
für die aufrechterhaltung der
solidarität die die unter druck geraten
sollen sicher sein können dass der rest
der familie hilft ganz schnell ein
überblick über die drei stockwerke
dieses hauses die kommissarin im herbst
an die details liefern ich beginne mit
der externen dimension bzw
aber zu der herkunft
durch reiseländern da kann ich folgendes
sagen europa braucht nachbarn über
partner in der welt um mit der situation
fertig zu werden
wir präsentieren heute einen
paradigmenwechsel aus der bedeutete wir
arbeiten mit all unseren partnern
zusammen
damit es auch so läuft seit 2015 haben
wir über 9 milliarden euro ausgegeben um
flüchtlingen und migranten außerhalb der
ihrigen zu unterstützen um ihr leben zu
retten millionen von gefährdeten sind
gerettet worden und wir haben viele die
die flüchtlinge unterstützt haben
ihrerseits unterstützt
wir arbeiten mit herkunfts und
transitländern zusammen mit das doch mit
dem ziel wir wollen denen helfen ihren
eigenen leuten zu helfen damit die stadt
ein besseres leben finden wo sie
herkommen stadt gewissenlosen managern
im mittelmeer oder in der ägäis in die
hände zu fallen
wir wollen natürlich gegen die schule
gehen
manager wollen bessere verfahren und sie
werden sehen wir intensivieren die
zusammenarbeit in allen bereichen die in
beziehungen zu drittstaaten werden wird
der wert legen auf eine win win
partnerschaft partnerschaft sind diese
antworten der unterstützen damit er sich
für beide seiten lohnt die drittland
partner wie auch strategisch vorgehen
flexibel mit einer klaren politik der eu
und wir haben ja auch den vorschlag für
ein instrument für nachbarschaft
entwicklung und internationale
zusammenarbeit
das ist finanziell gut ausgestattet über
70 milliarden
euro stehen zur verfügung um zehn
prozent migrations orientiert zum
zweiten stockwerk strikte überwachung
unserer grenzen es wird noch der neuen
system kontrollen alle ankömmlinge an
den außengrenzen leben bis sagen sie in
die mitgliedstaaten nur verpflichtet
fingerabdrücke von drinnen zu nehmen
die illegal ankommen sie müssen einfach
nur registriert werden mit dem neuen
paket müssen alle ankömmlinge gründlich
überprüft werden auf gesundheit auf
identität damit kann man die ankömmlinge
direkt das in die richtigen verfahren
einstufen
in einer zweiten phase ist es so dass
alle die keine aussicht auf asyl haben
weil sie aus einem land mit einer
niedrigen anerkennungsrate kommen also
diejenigen werden obligatorisch in einem
schnellverfahren an der grenze
übertragen damit ihre anträge schnell
abgewickelt werden können und die
rückkehr schnell in die wege geleitet
werden
das bedeutet nahtlos ineinandergreifen
das verfahren
es geht schnell wir vermeiden damit
engpässe assist und black holes so wie
wir sie im moment haben denn wie gesagt
im moment haben wir schon so sagen gar
keinen zuständen die betonung den
grenzen wird dann noch erkennst du durch
ein neues europäisches ökosystem das
wert lebte auf tatsächliche rückkehr
wird einen eu-koordinator für
rückkehr geben er und frontex werden
eine wichtige rolle spielen einer
operationelle rolle beim management der
eure kehren
anfang märz haben wir schon gesagte
europa kann effizient auftreten und
werden das auch weiter unter beweis
stellen
dann komme ich zum dritten stockwerk
unseres imaginären hauses was finden wir
im dritten stock nun also eine strikte
aber faire regeln auch für solidarität
die präsidentin sagte es sehr schön
wir reden hier nicht darüber ob es
solidarität gibt sondern wir reden
darüber wie solidarität
kurz und gut wir haben ein system
ständiger wirksamer solidarität
geschaffen die es immer geben wird die
immer die gewähr gibt dass ein wechsel
statt der in eine bestimmte situation
gerät auch die hilfe erfährt die er
braucht starke solidarität also über
diesen mechanismus mit diesem
mechanismus ignorieren wir natürlich
nicht die gezogenen roten linien aber
wir haben versucht lösungen zwischen den
rot million zu finden und das ist uns
gelungen wir haben ein neues konzept
geschaffen das nennen die rückkehr
sponsorship du mit dieser rückkehr
sponsorship kann man da einen neuen weg
beschreiten sich das sind nur zu
erläutern
also ist da ein konzept mit dem man in
konkurrenz stehen die interessen ins
gleichgewicht bringen könnte wir müssen
alle mitgliedstaaten akzeptieren
die zwingende neuansiedlung zugleich ist
es aber so dass neuansiedlung unter
umständen eine mitgliedsstaat wirkliche
entlastet wenn er unser hohen
flüchtlingsgruppe und gerät wir haben
nun mit dieser lösung versucht eine
brauchbare alternative zu bieten
um zu gewährleisten dass selbst event
nicht umgesiedelt wird dieselbe zahl von
menschen untergebracht werden kann und
die staaten die unter druck geraten
die können hilfe von den sponsor
mitgliedstaaten bekommen und damit
sollte das system für gleichgewicht
sorgen ist unsere mitgliedstaaten können
sich natürlich auf die nationalitäten
konzentrieren wo sie am besten helfen
können
dieses system natürlich so ausgelegt
sein dass man immer das wechselspiel hat
zwischen neuansiedlung einerseits und
unterstützung für rückkehrerin
andererseits seien sie dessen sicher wir
werden wert darauf legen dass immer
solidarität geübt werden solidarität
schienen organisiert werden
je nachdem in welcher situation sie sich
ein mitgliedstaat befindet er kann er
auf eine der angebotenen 3 erschienen
aufsteigen es kann eine krisensituation
sein es kann eine such und rettungs
situation sein und es kann sein dass das
besonderer druck entsteht oder zu
entstehen droht für jedes in china gibt
es wieder regeln und das üben von
solidarität
aber damit nicht genug für dessen wir
nicht es gibt einige dinge die noch
hinzukommen müssen das gestern etwas für
die nächste phase vergessen wir schengen
nicht schengen ist eines der wichtigsten
themen nächstes jahr werden eine
strategie für die zukunft von schengen
und vorlegen dann geht es auch um die
legale
migration das interesse an ehrgeizig
aber da brauchen wir den eigenen diskurs
und das müssen wir getrennt behandeln
von der diskussion über die irreguläre
migration
heute haben wir mit der öffentlichen
konsultation zur illegalen migration
begonnen
nächstes jahr geht es weiter wissen sie
nicht was ihm zusammen das ist ein neues
system
es ist sozusagen ein wunder neu anfangen
stellte fest alles hängt miteinander
zusammen ist wir gehen davon aus und der
neue europäische rahmen der neu besetzt
wird der sollte dafür sorgen dass wir
rational ordentlich nachvollziehbar mit
der migration in europa mit der politik
orientieren können wir jetzt einen
strich unter das bisherige für eine ganz
andere situation konzipierter für wenige
die einen diktatorischen diktator zu
entfliehen untersuchten heute ist die
situation anders will in zeiten
allgemeiner migration muss sagen wir
sind sehr stolz auf die europäische
union der größte und der rest
regulierter markt der welt wir haben die
zweitstärkste währung der welt
wir sind die besten in sachen bildung
und gesundheit bei uns gibt es keine
todesstrafe wir kümmern uns um uns
älteren menschen
wir haben alles bereitgestellt und
dessen er ist doch undenkbar dass in
riesa seite europa sich dann nicht auch
eine schlüssige asyl und
migrationspolitik geben kann mit diesem
paket hoffen gehört die lücke zu
schließen so da habe ich gerade noch mal
zusammen geschrieben was der eu
kommissar für förderung der europäischen
lebensweise margaritis chinas aus
griechenland gerade verkündet hat
ich fasse noch mal ganz kurz zusammen er
hat von einem imaginären haus gesprochen
das aus drei stockwerken besteht das
erste stockwerk ist quasi mehr geld und
mehr abkommen mit den herkunftsländern
auch für rückführungen aber auch solche
sachen wie der eu türkei flüchtlings die
das zweite stockwerk sind striktere
kontrollen der grenzen da sollen alle
orden konnte gründlicher geprüft werden
und wenn jemand wenig aussicht hat auf
eine auf ein asylverfahren dass ich ein
asyl anerkennung in der eu soll das auch
wohl methoden geben direkt an der grenze
diese menschen zu prüfen schnellere
verfahren soll es geben und dem dritten
stockwerk nannte r strikte regeln für
solidarität ein sogenanntes rückkehr
sponsorship also länder die jetzt keine
menschen aufnehmen sollen sollen länder
die menschen bei sich haben mehr
entlasten so und über dieses große neue
paket er sprach von einem neuen rahmen
und und einem strich unter dem
bisherigen system möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit gerald knaus soziologe und
migrationsforscher ist mir in berlin
zugeschaltet heraus sie haben alles
gerade mit angehört was ist denn so ihr
erstes fazit ist dass es tatsächlich ein
strich unter das bisherige dublin system
das ja doch viele probleme gemacht hat
also das was wir da bis jetzt gehört
haben auch schon in den letzten tagen
und jetzt noch einmal vom vize
präsidentin der kommission wird für mich
viel mehr fragen auf als es antworten
gibt es sind einige dinge die vernünftig
gingen aber die frage die man sich dann
stellt ist wie wird das jetzt umgesetzt
wenn es schon vorher nicht geklappt hat
und es sind einige dinge die mich sehr
skeptisch und ratlos zurücklassen also
diese idee und das am meisten also was
lässt sie am meisten ratlos und
skeptisch zurück wo man sie was könnte
nicht klappen von dem was er gerade
vorgestellt hat das ich überlege mir wie
das heute bei den brennenden problemen
die wir haben auf den griechischen
inseln im zentralen mittelmeer mit der
seenotrettung oder etwa in deutschland
bei der abschiebung von
ausreisepflichtigen wie das konkret
funktionieren würde
also ich versuche mir das vorzustellen
und jetzt nehmen wir mal die situation
in der ägäis also in lesbos oder auf den
anderen inseln die idee dass wir
partnerschaften brauchen
das ist ohne jeden zweifel war wenn wir
wollen dass weniger irreguläre migration
vor allem von leuten die keinen schutz
in der eu brauchen erfolgt dann brauchen
wir partner wir hatten das vier jahre
mit der türkei die frage ist jetzt was
bieten wir diesen partnern an
wir haben ein abkommen mit der türkei
und nach vier jahren hat die europäische
union kein angebot mehr gemacht dass
vernünftig und fair wäre angesichts der
tatsache dass die türken über
dreieinhalb millionen flüchtlinge haben
also machen wir jetzt ein angebot für
die türkei für den libanon für jordanien
um die menschen die dort sind besser zu
unterstützen dass sie dort bleiben oder
nicht das klang ja doch so also ja das
ist also die frage ist dann gibt es das
geld sind die eu-mitgliedsländer bereit
damals war 6 milliarden für die letzten
vier jahre
es wäre gut wenn es so wäre aber dann
kommen wir zur zweiten frage kann ich
dann auch mal kurz rein rutschen sie
haben ja auch diesen eu türkei
flüchtling stil damals vorgeschlagen und
mit eingetütet halten sie den
tatsächlich für einen guten mechanismus
also die menschen werden quasi in der
türkei aufgehalten dürfen nicht weiter
die türkei hat dreieinhalb millionen
menschen bei sich aufgenommen denen so
hört man ist ja auch nicht besonders gut
gehen soll in dem land ist das
tatsächlich eine lösung dann einfach da
eine grenze hoch zu ziehen und sagen ja
dann kümmert sich halt jemand anders
herum
naja wenn sie nur das wäre dann hätte ja
die türkei das den europäern nicht
vorgeschlagen es war ja ein türkischer
vorschlag im märz zwei 16 und die türken
haben gesagt wir haben hier millionen
flüchtlinge wir sind auch bereit ihnen
eine perspektive zu bieten die syrer
hatten schon davor und jetzt immer noch
zugang zum gesundheitssystem haben einen
dauerhaften status der ist nicht
begrenzt zeitlich ihre kinder gehen in
türkische schulen sie kriegen von der eu
finanziert sozialhilfe und die türken
gesagt wenn ihr wollt dass das klappt
dann müsst ihr uns solidarisch helfen
wir haben im jahr haben sie geschätzt 5
milliarden euro kosten für diese
millionen flüchtlinge und die eu dazu
gesagt für vier jahre jeweils einen über
eine milliarde eineinhalb milliarden pro
jahr in dieser konkreten bereiche
bildung schule sozialhilfe zu stecken
die frage ist macht die eu weiter und in
den letzten monaten war das nicht
vorgesehen in den budget diskussionen in
brüssel
wenn sich das ändern würde wenn diese
rhetorik über partner bedeutet dass wir
ländern die sehr sehr viel mehr
flüchtlinge haben pro kopf als die
europäer zusammen also auch der libanon
auch jordanien weiterhin substanziell
helfen wollen dann ist das im interesse
aller der flüchtlinge dort der türken
und europäer aber das was nicht geklappt
hat die letzten jahre und da kommen wir
zum kern der neuen vorschläge war nicht
die unterstützung in der türkei sondern
was mit den leuten passiert die
griechenland erreicht haben das was wir
sehen
die katastrophale die inhumanen zustände
in den lagern geht darauf zurück dass
die europäische union in der lage war
oder nie wie ist denn die zahlen waren
ja anfangs auch kleine sind ja für viele
jahre lang von 216 bis mitte 219 nie
mehr als im durchschnitt 3000 menschen
auf alle inseln gekommen im monat
wir waren nie in der lage nie willens
die menschen menschenwürdig
unterzubringen und schnelle verfahren zu
machen jetzt klingt das gut schnelle
verfahren aber wir haben natürlich auch
eine flüchtlingskonvention wir haben
vorgaben wir haben die notwendigkeit
auch in berufung zu gehen gegen
ablehnungen und dafür brauchte seine
administration eine verwaltung wir
brauchen ein flüchtling asylsysteme wir
haben in deutschland die größte
asylbehörde der welt das bamf die hat
viel gelernt in den letzten jahren viel
kapazitäten aufgebaut
in griechenland hat das nie geklappt in
italien hat das nie geklappt in spanien
hat das nie geklappt und ich sehe noch
nicht konkret wie das jetzt auf lesbos
in den nächsten monaten bis zum winter
für die 12.000 menschen die jetzt dort
sind klappen wird das wird der test sein
und ich das letzte vielleicht zu den
abschiebungen dritte eine zentrale frage
natürlich brauchen wir ein system wo die
die in der eu keinen schutz bekommen
abgeschoben werden
aber mir fehlt in diesen vorschlägen
jeder realismus wir haben noch nie so
wenige abschiebungen gehabt aus der
europäischen union
wie im letzten halben jahr und woraus
deutschland wurden in der ersten
jahreshälfte insgesamt geschätzt 1000
menschen außerhalb von europa
ausreisepflichtige außerhalb von europa
zurück gebracht
1000 den sechs monaten es geht anderen
ländern nicht viel besser jetzt sind in
diesem jahr nur sehr wenige menschen
gekommen über das mittelmeer aber es
waren immer noch über 50.000 die in den
letzten neun monaten über das mittelmeer
gekommen sind
wie passt das zusammen was ist der
realismus hier gibt es einen stichtag
wie mit der eu dem der eu türkei
erklärung ab dem leute zurückgeführt
werden sind die die jetzt in moria sind
geben wir endlich die wahrheit zu dass
diese menschen nicht zurückgeschickt
werden können weil weder die türkei noch
rückführung nach afghanistan derzeit
möglich sind das fehlt mir der realismus
bei diesem auf den ersten blick gut
klingenden vorschlag die die
ausreisepflichtig sind schneller
abzuschieben kann sehr sehr leichter zu
führen wenn es der realismus fehlt dass
leute geparkt werden in irgendwelchen
zentren und dann dort auf alle ewigkeit
ohne perspektive unter unmenschlichen
zuständen wie wir das jetzt gesehen
haben ausharren müssen und das wäre eine
katastrophe würde ich fast noch mal kurz
zusammen für alle zuschauer die es nicht
den kompletten live stream verfolgt
haben wir haben uns umgehört was die eu
kommission an vorschlägen hat das eu
migrations und asylsystem zu
überarbeiten
der vizepräsident der eu-kommission
margaritis hamas ausrichten land hat da
gesprochen dass es ein strich geben wird
unter das bisherige system ich spreche
darunter darüber mit gerald knaus
soziologe migrations vorstand gerade in
berlin zugeschaltet und er ist doch sehr
skeptisch und sagt das fehlt ihm an
realismus ich muss noch mal nachfragen
heraus das ist ja jetzt quasi einen
rahmen der für die nächsten jahre wenn
nicht jahrzehnte gelten soll
ist das nicht ein bisschen viel verlangt
dass man dann auch die tatsächlichen
kleinen probleme anguckt und ist das ist
das nicht eher eine sache die man
vielleicht auf bilateralem wege lösen
kann zum beispiel jetzt in dem die
bundesregierung anderer länder sagt ja
wir holen die menschen aus moriya zu uns
und dann gucken wir erst mal dass das
dass die kuh vom eis
also ich gebe mal eine positive
interpretation wie das ganze vielleicht
funktionieren könnte also erster stock
partnerschaften sagen wir wir machen
eine partnerschaft mit tunesien in
diesem jahr kamen 8000 tunesien über das
mittelmeer
wir bieten
ähnlich viel an wie der ukraine das war
ist zb auch die visafreie einreise für
ukrainische bürger als touristen bis zu
drei monaten
und dafür nimmt tunesien jeden tunesier
der ausreisepflichtig ist sofort zurück
das wäre ein konkretes angebot darüber
habe ich aber noch nicht viel gehört
keine details dann würde tunesien sagen
alle tunesier die wir retten im
mittelmeer die wir nach lampedusa oder
oder malta bringen werden wenn sie einen
asylantrag stellen der wird schnell
bearbeitet auch dazu das wäre
realistisch wenn man die ressourcen
hätte die nehmen wir zurück dann höre
dass dieses phänomen auf das wäre das
wäre umsetzbar wir könnten etwas
ähnliches mit marokko machen
wir könnten auch marokko sagen wir
bieten an etwas attraktives dass die zum
beispiel in marokko den ausbau des
asylsystems so weiter treiben dass wir
sagen können es gibt in marokko ein
glaubwürdiges asylsystem das wäre
sinnvoll
wir könnten auch sagen wir machen
partnerschaften mit herkunftsländern die
realistisch sind wir wir reden mit
nigeria und gambia oder senegal und
sagen wir schicken alle die zurück die
ab einem stichtag nach europa kommen und
keinen schutz brauchen mit dem ziel dass
die leute sich gar nicht mehr auf den
weg machen und wir schicken sofort alle
straftäter zurück das gelingt derzeit
auch nicht zur situation vieler
innenminister also das wären
realistischer interpretationen der
prinzipien aber wofür ich große angst
habe ist dieses prinzip der abschiebe
des ab der abschiebe das
abschlusskonzert das glaube ich genannt
hat vize-präsident dass wir länder dass
wir leute die abzuschieben sind irgendwo
in die länder schieben die keine
flüchtlinge aufnehmen wollen dass die
dann dort in ähnlichen zentren lagern
gefängnissen ausharren
das erscheint mir nicht sehr gut
durchdacht und das ist doch eine
zentrale frage denn ohne abschiebung
realismus für die die keinen schutz
brauchen die dadurch auch entmutigt
werden sich auf den weg zu machen kann
ein faires und schnelles asylsystem das
mehrheitsfähig ist auch schwer
funktionieren da da müssen wir wirklich
realistisch sein und brauchen
mechanismen die nicht nur wunschdenken
beruhen
herr klaus
vor sich die junge sache geäußert haben
vor der presse hat eu
kommissionspräsident in ursula von der
leyen auch ein statement gegeben wir
haben da mal einen kurzen auszug von
abgeklappert
wir werden eng mit den griechischen
behörden zusammenarbeiten um auf lesbos
ein aufnahmezentrum aufzubauen
wir haben eine task force gegründet um
mit hilfe der eu behörden die
lebensbedingungen für menschen auf der
insel dauerhaft zu verbessern help
improve conditions for people an die
island wir müssen gemeinsam zeigen dass
europa migration in einer humanen und
effektive weise organisieren kann so und
wenn ich sie richtig verstanden habe ja
klaus haben sie da ihre zweifel dass das
gelingen kann wie drängend das problem
ist kann man auch daran sehen kurz bevor
die pressekonferenz losgehen gab es
meldungen von nachrichtenagenturen dass
das rettungsschiff alanco die von der
organisation sea works kurs genommen hat
auch marcel mit 200 ich muss noch mal
kurz die zahlen nachgucken 200 125
migranten weil sie einfach in italien
keine landeerlaubnis bekommen haben die
behörden haben da völlig gemauert und
sie hoffen jetzt einfach nur dass
frankreich die menschen aufnimmt was
würden sie sich in solchen fällen
wünschen also glauben sie tatsächlich
dass die eu kommission mit diesen
rahmenbedingungen oder mit diesen neuen
ideen die sie jetzt vorgestellt hat da
so kurzfristig helfen kann oder müssen
uns daran gewöhnen dass genau diese
problematik auf dem mittelmeer dass
menschen nicht wissen wo sie hinkommen
dass menschen weiter in zeltlagern
bleiben müssten die nächsten monate noch
weiter geht also zunächst glaube ich
dass die kommissionspräsident den recht
hat wenn sie davon spricht dass der test
dieser neuen strategie nicht dass den
einigen monaten erfolgen kann nicht das
wenn sie angenommen ist sondern heute
auf den griechischen inseln also
zumindest bis zum winter muss es möglich
sein dort menschenwürdige bedingungen zu
schaffen
eigentlich müssten diese inseln jetzt
evakuiert werden denn die menschen haben
dort unerträglich viel gelitten und sie
werden ohnehin nirgendwo zurückgebracht
also das ist wichtig und die idee eines
pilot aufnahme zentrums die frage ist
dann was ist und da übernimmt die eu
sehr viel verantwortung was ist der sinn
dieses
zentrums ist der sinn dieses zentrums
menschen noch einmal 18 monate
festzuhalten ist der sinn des zentrums
für eine relativ kleine zahl von
menschen menschenwürdige unterbringung
zu schaffen das wäre sehr gut ist der
sinn des zentrums sicherzustellen dass
niemand länger als ein paar wochen auf
eine asyl entscheidung wartet und damit
auf die entscheidung wohin die person
gebracht wird das wäre auch sehr gut
das liegt am ende auch an der frage und
wie viele menschen es gehen soll also
für 12.000 menschen ist so ein zentrum
das menschlich sein soll nicht denkbar
wenn es ein paar hundert oder tausend
sind mit einem neuen stichtag die
ankommen und die dann wirklich
menschenwürdig untergebracht werden ist
das sinnvoll und was die seenotrettung
betrifft wir haben es in diesem jahr mit
sehr sehr geringen zahlen zu tun es wäre
durchaus denkbar dass alle die die von
europäischen schiffen auch von den ngo
schiffen gerettet werden wenn man sie
nach malta bringt wenn man sie nach
lampedusa und sizilien bringt und
sicherstellt und den ländern
aufnahmeländern erstaufnahme ländern
garantiert niemand bleibt dort länger
als acht wochen in diesen acht wochen
treffen wir eine faire entscheidung mit
genug ressourcen und da wäre es am
besten direkt auf die expertise des bamf
oder der französischen asylbehörde
ritter niederländischen oder anderer
zurückzugreifen
wir treffen in wenigen wochen eine faire
entscheidung und dann brauchen wir
natürlich diese partnerschaften mit
herkunftsländern oder auch sicheren
transitstaaten das schließt libyen aus
aber es wäre denkbar dass tunesien sagt
ab einem stichtag also ab jetzt nehmen
wir leute die dann in der eu keinen
schutz bekommen nach einem fairen
verfahren nehmen wir auf das würde dazu
führen dass viel weniger leute kommen
wir hätten weniger tote die die schutz
bekommen würden wir dann allerdings
natürlich von malta oder italien in der
eu verteilen müssen das wären derzeit in
diesem jahr im letzten jahr im jahr
davor
keine hohen zahlen es würde dazu führen
dass weniger menschen im brutto steigen
weniger menschen sterben also wenn das
gemeint ist dann wäre das ein schritt in
die richtige richtung aber ich fürchte
dass die italiener die malteser und
andere nie zustimmen werden weil sie
natürlich das schreckliche bild von
maria vor augen haben wenn nicht
garantiert ist dass alle die in diesen
zentren von den seenotrettern
hingebracht werden
da innerhalb von einigen wochen
garantiert abgenommen werden und das zu
sicherzustellen
diese zusagen wirklich zu bekommen und
dann auch sicherzustellen dass wir in
der lage sind die die keinen schutz
brauchen zumindest einen teil auch
zurückzuführen die herkunftsländer die
migrations diplomatie dazu dass
zusammenzubringen ist eine
herkulesaufgabe deutschland frankreich
und andere länder müssten sich da
einbringen dann könnte das gehen dass
der kommission zu belassen halte ich für
unrealistisch
herr klaus kann man wirklich das wird
einem der kopf wenn man diese ganzen
ungelösten probleme sieht die jetzt
irgendwie angegangen werden müssen mit
einer eu die sich ja nicht wirklich
einig ist wir haben natürlich jetzt zu
dem thema viele user kommentare und
fragen bekommen ich habe jetzt mal so
ein paar ausgewählt bekommen von meiner
redaktion also einmal auf facebook
das statement von marazzi wie wollen sie
identität feststellen wenn keine papiere
mitgeführt werden das hängt dann ja
direkt an diesen abkommen wenn die
menschen wissen sie werden abgeschoben
weil sie aus einem land kommen wo man er
dann kein asyl bekommt dann kann man
natürlich auch nachvollziehen dass sie
dafür sorgen dass das nicht
nachvollziehbar ist in solchen fällen
ist dann die uhr einfach ausgeschlossen
oder harnos naja nicht ganz ich war in
vielen auch aufnahmezentren habe auch
viel vielen polizisten gesprochen
das entscheidet die sind wir die
kooperation der herkunftsländer es gibt
menschen da kann man ohne deren aussage
nicht feststellen woher sie kommen aber
die meisten heutzutage wenn die
herkunftsländer kooperieren kann man
durch gespräche man kann durch ihre
mobiltelefone die niederländer machen
dass etwa bei sehr vielen menschen doch
feststellen aus welchen ländern sie
kommen und wenn sie ein asylantrag
stellen und das ist ja das recht eines
jeden dann müssen sie auch eine
geschichte erzählen
das entscheidet ist ob dann ihre
herkunftsländer diese identifizierung
anerkennen also werden wenn wir sagen
dass ich ungefähr abkommen brown aber
mit damit das funktioniert dann geht es
vor facebook ein kommentar von mirko
maier ein effektiver grenzschutz würde
vollkommen reichen
ist das tatsächlich das einzige mittel
es wurde auch angekündigt von der
eu-kommission es wird einen härteren
grenzschutz geben aber gerade in
situationen wo der menschen trotzdem
versuchen sich in booten über das
mittelmeer zu retten hilft dann ja im
grunde eigentlich nur die menschen
aufzunehmen und was passiert dann mit
denen also eine sache habe ich nicht
gehört in der rede des
kommissionspräsidenten und das war das
wort menschenrechte oder die
flüchtlingskonvention die gelten aber
derzeit also das ist ja geltendes recht
in der eu und die sehen natürlich vor
dass wir gewisse dinge nicht tun dürfen
also wenn jemand griechische gewässer
erreicht in einem boot dann heißt das
nicht dass wir diese personen einen
aufenthalt in europa garantieren müssen
aber diese person hat gewisse rechte und
das recht nicht zurück gestoßen zu
werden in die türkei ohne eine prüfung
ist grundlegend in der
flüchtlingskonvention also dieses reden
vom strengen grenzschutz wenn das
bedeutet dass wir wollen wir
identifizieren wollen wäre nach europa
kommt dass wir prüfen wollen das ist
alles vollkommen legitim und eigentlich
sollten wir das schon längst machen aber
es kann nicht bedeuten dass menschen die
europa erreichen und einen asylantrag
stellen wollen dafür bestraft werden
denn die gründe die der
flüchtlingskonvention nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg war ja dass das was wir erlebt
haben oder schweizer deutschen grenze in
der zeit des dritten reiches dass juden
von den schweizer behörden
zurückgestoßen wurden ins dritte reich
und dann oft in konzentrationslager
kamen dass diese erfahrung dass das in
europa und weltweit nie wieder möglich
sein soll also wir müssen prüfen
ja jetzt ist die türkei nicht das dritte
reich wir können auch leute zurück
schicken aber es gibt asyl ansprüche und
brutal menschen an land oder seegrenzen
einfach durch gewalt zurück zu stoßen
ist derzeit in der flüchtlingskonvention
für alle europäer illegal also das
können wir aber wohl trotzdem gemacht
auch wenn es wird aufgehalten oder haben
sie eigentlich der probleme der brechen
wir unsere eigenen gesetze
dann gibt es natürlich hier die ich sage
mal in den letzten jahren schon
bekannten position auf youtube schreibt
michael iv ich denke wir haben in
deutschland schlimme zustände warum
beginnt man nicht einmal zuerst hier mit
den problemen und dann gibt es quasi die
gegenposition die sagt auch auf youtube
von us- grotowski es geht darum akut
gefährdete leben zu retten
menschen sterben nicht nur wegen aus
deutschland exportierten waffen sondern
auch fähigen restriktive asylpolitik und
nicht helfen der politik also beide
probleme sind da natürlich muss man in
deutschland auch helfen ich glaube dass
gegeneinander auszuspielen ist immer
schwierig weil die welt hängt halt
miteinander zusammen
und dann geht es hier noch einen
kommentar auch von newscode horsky bitte
gleichzeitig ausreichend legale
migrations möglichkeiten schaffen da gab
es so einen ganz kurzen ganz kurzen ton
gerade von der eu kommission dass der
schengen raum neu aufgestellt werden
soll da dann neu verhandelt werden soll
mit legalen migrations möglichkeiten
aber so richtig mit der bitte um eine
kurze antwort hinaus ist da noch nicht
bewegung drin dass man sich wirklich
überlegt wie kann man dann dafür sorgen
dass die menschen egal herkommen können
ohne sich in lebensgefahr zu bringen
ja so wir haben das eine problem dass
schutzbedürftige also leute die bei uns
asyl bekämen oder bekommen derzeit
keinen anderen weg haben in die eu zu
kommen als irregulär mit schmugglern
rheindt einzureisen also die aufnahme
die neuansiedlung oder resettlement von
schutzbedürftigen ist heute auf dem
niedrigsten niveau weltweit das zu
ändern wäre eine gute initiative und das
zweite ist dass legale migration
natürlich auch ein anderer als ist für
starten und jetzt rede ich einfach nur
über legales reisen nicht einfach nicht
kommen und zu arbeiten aber legales
reisen für touristen zu kooperieren bei
der rücknahme von ausreisepflichtigen
das ist kein zufall dass ist deutschland
eigentlich nur gelingt abschiebungen in
die länder ein größerer zahl zu machen
deren bürger legal einreisen können die
haben ein interesse zu kooperieren die
balkanländer die ukraine moldau georgien
währenddessen alle länder afrikas von
denen kein einziges land bürgt oder die
bürger keines einzigen landes visafrei
einreisen können
diese länder kooperieren auch nicht und
nicht nur mit deutschland nicht auch
nicht mit frankreich spanien oder
italien und hier zu überlegen was wollen
wir
legale einreise dafür sind in der lage
die die ausreisepflichtig sind sehr
schnell abzuschieben natürlich
straftäter aber auch andere die nicht
das recht haben hier zu bleiben das hat
deutschland mit dem balkan gemacht und
die balkan länder die früher eingereist
seien um asylanträge zu stellen heute
haben die leute die möglichkeit legal us
touristen zu kommen
sie haben auch eine möglichkeit ein
arbeits visum zu beantragen
aber dafür gehabt noch alle
abschiebungen von ausreisepflichtigen
heraus ich danke ihnen jetzt für diese
einschätzungen und ihrer expertise heute
und die beantwortung der fragen
wir gucken noch mal ganz kurz zu meinem
kollegen stefan leifert nach brüssel der
sich alles angehört hat weil die große
frage ist ja was passiert jetzt weiter
stefan das klang jetzt alles wenn ich
mir das an höre wirklich wirklich
kompliziert mit sehr sehr vielen
institutionen die miteinander auskommen
müssen kannst du mal ganz kurz
skizzieren wie das jetzt weitergeht und
ob das vielleicht ist es auch das
problem dass es so lange dauert das so
viele menschen mit am herd mit versuchen
so ein eu migration stil zu kochen
klar so ist europa hinaus hat das ganze
ja gerade eine herkulesaufgabe genannt
und was er damit meinte war der aspekt
der technischen umsetzung wo er sehr
viele fragezeichen und sehr viele
zweifel geäußert hat dem ganzen geht ja
noch eine herkulesaufgabe voraus und das
ist der politische prozess die
politische einigung und was wir heute
erlebt haben ist allenfalls der beginn
eines prozesses von dem wir noch gar
nicht wissen ob er überhaupt zu einer
einigung führt die dann dazu führen
würde dass all das umgesetzt wird
vorübergehen aus eben gesprochen hat
also die nächsten wochen und monate
werden davon geprägt sein dass das was
die kommission jetzt heute vorgestellt
hat
in die mitgliedsländer geht 27 stück die
müssen zustimmen und dann geht das ganze
auch noch ins europaparlament und diesen
drei von der eu kommission parlament und
den mitgliedsstaaten muss dann am ende
eine einigung erzielt werden und wenn
man sich anguckt wie lange wir jetzt mit
diesem streit staat zu tun haben denn
ich fünf jahre ohne eine aussicht auf
einigung dann ahnt man wie lange diese
politische einigung die uns jetzt
bevorsteht noch daran müsste alle länder
denn da tatsächlich einig sein oder kann
man auch sagen diejenigen die gar nicht
kooperieren die das problem quasi gar
nicht angehen können die können wir erst
mal ausklammern weil die sind nicht
konstruktiv das ist auch so ein
dauerbrenner in der eu theoretisch wäre
es möglich mit einer einfachen mehrheit
das ganze zu beschließen und
durchzusetzen wir haben das ja schon mal
erlebt das hat die eu-kommission mit den
vorschlägen von jean claude juncker
schon mal gemacht
da ging es eher um die umsiedlung von
über 100.000 flüchtlingen das hat aber
nicht funktioniert weil nicht alle
länder mitgemacht haben und das waren
daneben auch die die nicht zugestimmt
haben und die überstimmt worden sind
aber die muss man korrigieren können
denke ich jetzt als es noch mal brüssel
laie dass man einfach sagt wer nicht
mitmacht der kriegt zum beispiel weniger
subventionen
theoretisch geht es aber auch darüber
müsste man sich erst einmal einigen wir
haben das gleiche ja gerade bei der
frage der rechtsstaatlichkeit also der
frage kann man ländern mittel entziehen
wenn sie sich nicht an die
rechtsstaatlichkeit prinzipien halten
hier beim thema migration haben das ja
mit geltendem eu recht zu tun was
gebrochen oder nicht eingehalten wird
kommission geht dann vor den eugh vor
den europäischen gerichtshof aber das
problem ist das dauert alles wahnsinnig
lange und gerald knaus hat ja in die
dringlichkeit des problems geschehen
also das wäre hier einfach keine lösung
jetzt gibt es nur noch eine frage von
einem user wo habe ich sie denn gehabt
genau wo martina auf youtube ist es
realistisch dass im rahmen dieses neuen
asylsystem ist manchmal gar keine
flüchtlinge aufnehmen müssen
das war hat der eu-kommissar und eu
vizepräsident der kommission nicht so
direkt gesagt aber das war so
verklausuliert zuhören glaube ich das
ist dann diese ich muss mal kurz gucken
wie es genannt hatte ich mir
aufgeschrieben dass rückkehr sponsorship
glaube ich war dieses system das man
dann quasi ländern hilft die menschen
aufnehmen aber selber niemanden
aufnehmen muss ist das tatsächlich eine
realistische gangbare lösung oder wird
dann nicht auch jemand wie griechenland
oder italien sagen was soll das denn das
bitte also man sieht schon an diesen
begriffen dass die von der leyen
kommission wahnsinnig gut darin ist sich
immer wieder neue schillernde
überschriften und begriffe für recht
technische prinzipien auszudenken aber
um die frage zu beantworten ja der jetzt
vorgestellte plan sieht vor dass man
helfen kann und teilt dieses
solidaritäts mechanismus es sein kann
ohne flüchtlinge aufzunehmen und das der
schlüsselbegriff dazu ist dieses
rückführung sponsor schiff das machen
was konkret in griechenland ist über 50
afghanische flüchtlinge entschieden
worden dass die kein aufenthaltsrecht
haben und dass die zurückgeführt werden
sollen
dann würde jetzt über brüssel ein land
gesucht sagen wir ungarn und für
diese 50 afghanen verantwortlich erklärt
und umgang ist dann dafür verantwortlich
und muss das finanzieren und den
rücktransport organisieren und vor allem
das ganze bürokratische was ja sehr
schwierig sein kann erledigen und
griechenland wäre dann insofern
entlastet als es sich nicht um die
rückführung dieser 50 afghanischen
geflüchteten kümmern musste das ist die
idee dahinter klaus hat große zweifel
daran dass das funktioniert und dass das
vor allem in den fristen und in den
zeiten funktioniert wieder nötig sind
aber das ist zumindest die idee und ja
es gibt künftig keine absolute pflicht
mehr flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
ich habe ja noch eine interessante frage
auf facebook von marion wenzel die fragt
warum werden die sozialleistungen für
migranten nicht europaweit einheitlich
geregelt und entsprechend angeglichen
die anziehungskraft manche
aufnahmeländer insbesondere deutschland
für du so auf null reduziert und das
problem der armut migration entsprechend
entzerrt werden
hast du eine antwort darauf stefan es
gab in der vergangenheit immer wieder
den versuch die standards die
sozialleistungen die kriterien all das
anzugleichen in vielen punkten glaube
ich ist das auch nicht unrealistisch bei
der frage der leistung ist das problem
dass es einfach sehr unterschiedliche
lebensstandards in den europäischen
ländern gibt deswegen wäre es
unrealistisch zu sagen ein geflüchteter
der in deutschland aufgenommen wird
bekommt das gleiche wie ein flüchtling
der in rumänien sein leben bestreiten
muss ich glaube in dem punkt ist es
unrealistisch dass es zu einer
angleichung kommt in den fragen der
kriterien wer hat schutzrecht und wer
nicht da ist das möglich stefan vielen
dank dass du heute mittag zeit für uns
hatte es das ganze für uns mit uns
verfolgt heißt die ganzen fragen
beantwortet hast und ich bedanke mich
auch bei euch und ihnen für die
kommentare für die aufmerksamkeit es ist
ein schwieriges thema und wir haben es
gerade gehört es wird uns wohl noch eine
ganze lange weile begleiten wir bleiben
wie immer dran für sie und für euch
sollten jetzt aber erstmal bis bald und
tschüss